there's another quote that you put in
here saying according to pew research 51
of men between the ages of 18 and 29 are
single compared to 32 percent of women
in the same age group
ah
how the [ __ ] does that work because this
the gender split of men and women is
around about 50 50.
well it probably works because there's
there's probably uh
a small percentage of men or an outside
proportion of men probably a small
percentage of men that are dating a lot
of these women and when
probably perceive that they're in a
relationship with these men when in
actuality he's probably dating a variety
of different women and you know tied to
that concept of that 51 of men is the
notion that the reason why they're
single is primarily because they're too
afraid to ask a woman out and it goes
back to that concept we're talking about
rejection so
guys using only fans it sort of takes
away the sting of rejection
yes what was that the ineffectiveness of
simping lies in its pedestrialization of
women in the absence of genuine intimacy
while the gentleman holds doors and pays
for dinner and engages in the women with
women on an emotional level the simp
inundates a woman with extravagant gifts
and superficial praise the simp engages
in romantic bribery attempting to buy a
woman's love and that's just
not gonna work no it doesn't because i
look i i'm of the belief that women are
masters at spotting [ __ ] they can
see it a mile away especially when it
comes to romantic conquest and if a man
is not genuine in his intentions and his
his courtship of her she's gonna spot
that very very quickly
how would a simp not be genuine
well if it's always about giving undue
praise and gifts well there's there's
something wrong there right if there
isn't any
pure emotional interaction if there is
isn't any need to engage her beyond
simply giving her praise and attention
well he's not really going to get
through the front door is he uh so
there's a there's a
underwritten expected reciprocation
which isn't being adhered to
yes and there's sort of this cat mouse
game that you could probably play with
the girl that you're trying to court
right i think that push and push and
pull uh process is what it's referred to
and if if all you're doing is giving
attention to a female your attention is
worthless
it's like getting getting too much of
something makes it makes it essentially
worthless so you know i don't know what
your favorite food is but let's say you
love pizza if you had pizza every single
day it no longer becomes your favorite
food because you're eating it on a daily
basis and it loses its luster over time
and the same thing applies with
attention in this case here where the
value of a man's attention is lost if
it's constant
the number of men aged 18 to 30 who
report having no sex in the past year
has tripled between 2008 and 2018. so
this is pre-pandemic and i imagine it
must have gotten an awful lot worse
through the pandemic as well why do you
think this is happening
it was probably higher than 31 percent
of whatever it was when it was reported
because that's not something that a lot
of men would actually report to people
it's sort of it's stigmatized right the
male the male virgin is something which
is stigmatized within society but i
think the reason why this is is
again it's a complex question which
probably has a multivariate answer yeah
so
it could be the case that it's men being
pushed out of the sexual marketplace
because women are typically looking for
a guy
at uh at the you know the 10 the 90th
percentile right the power few as it
were at the end of the power law
distribution
that could be a potential reason so
they're not finding
women that are necessarily interested in
them because they are let's say average
right socioeconomically speaking it
could be the case that they've actually
dropped out of the sexual marketplace so
excessive use of pornography playing
video games not putting themselves in a
situation in which they can court women
and actually
engage with them
that is probably another reason why
for me i think that's that's a big two
but go on go on that's interesting so i
think
you know black pill intel culture red
pill kevin samuels fans everyone wants
to blame the lack of sex or the vast
majority of people want to blame the
lack of sex on a women's standards being
too high or at least for the
people who aren't familiar with this
corner of the internet that's a
a big explanation but the fact that some
men have chosen to retreat from dating
because there's simply other more fun
things to do you know it's not just
about
the
black pills that can't and the red pills
that won't
it's the mgtows that choose not to
yes men that go their own way absolutely
correct and like a lot of this comes
down to effort if if you actually want
to have a girlfriend and actually have a
meaningful relationship with a girl
you're gonna have to try you're gonna
have to put your yourself out there and
you're gonna have to suffer rejection
rejection i think is a is a large part
about um
it really is a masculine feature so
dealing with rejection of course females
as well can deal with rejection but
dealing with rejection handling it is
how you you build a backbone right it's
how you develop a thick skin and the
more times you suffer rejection in you
know when it comes to dating and
courtship
the better you are at it
why do you think
we are so terrified of rejection as men
pain
suffering no one likes to feel as though
they're inadequate and
jordan peterson actually again go back
to going back to him he has this uh
fantastic line
about um when a man suffers rejection
when he's when a woman says no to him
she's essentially saying that she
doesn't want to reproduce with you and
uh carry on your genetic line and it's a
it's a fundamental shot to the ego and
nobody wants that
but you know
again if you do want to actually achieve
that right to spread your um your genes
as it were you're gonna have to take
hits
do you think that women feel the same
pain of rejection just that they ask
less frequently than men and that they
will passively get they are uh how would
you say
they're getting passive traffic
and men are having to create active
adverts uh to use the online marketing
vernacular
yes good good uh good uh terms there
good phraseology how many girls have
actively asked you out
it's in dude over 15 years of being out
and about on nights out i can remember
most of them i'm talking single digits
yes as can i it's like maybe two
it's not that much right and so women
aren't taking the you know the
the active effort to engage with a man
and ask him for his number and so
therefore they don't suffer as much
rejection but when they do suffer the
rejection i can imagine that it's pretty
damn painful because it's not in your
nature let's say to actually put
yourself out there and initiate the
conversation or initiate the engagement
oh so you've already overcome something
you've already decided to make an
increased effort on top of what you
think should be done this is outside my
normal operating process
schedule and it still hasn't worked well
if there's i want to hear
the girls that are listening
put a comment on youtube or whatever and
and tell us what you think because if
let us know what the pain of rejection
is like uh and whether or not whether or
not you think it's as bad as your male
counterparts
yes fascinating i i would love to see
the uh the comment yeah well we need you
to do a date to dive on it um yeah it's
a weird one man i
do not think
is there something deeper than that is
the what would it be evolutionarily why
would it be the case that
a woman saying no is so painful is it
that
there is a limited number of women and
that this is a reminder of your place in
the status hierarchy within the tribe of
the 100 people that you know and of
those hundred people maybe
four of them are available women that
are of the right age for you
yes it's a
it's probably a mark of inadequacy
so being told no that one cannot
reproduce is
is very painful
and evolutionary speaking uh
most of we have more female ancestors
than we do male ancestors which
indicates that a
small percentage of men in antiquity in
ancient times actually reproduced
and so
this is a good thing and a bad thing in
a way it's bad obviously because a lot
of men are dying without reproducing but
it's probably a good thing in a sense
because women are
selecting the best possible mates and so
it sort of it it improves our genetic
line when all the the top stock males
are selected what's happening people if
you enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace
you